>> March 8th, 2014, a day I
remember well, it was a launch
of this program, my program on
CNN, also the day, more
importantly, that mh three 70
disappeared, which marks the
start of one of the biggest
aviation mysteries of all-time,
the plane carrying 239 postures
and crew members, it was set to
arrive in beijing after
departing from Kuala Lumpur but
has never been seen since.
Coverage then took over our
airways and everybody else is,
four months after that.
And yet, despite launching the
largest aviation search in
history, virtually nothing was
found of the aircraft, varies
on high plane could vanish into
thin air have grip the world
for almost a decade, but so far
none have been proven, now,
Netflix is streaming a
brand-new three episode
docuseries called mh370, they
play in the disappeared,
investigating the still
unsolved mystery, Jeff wise is
an aviation journalist who
plays an important role in the
Netflix series.
He is the author of the book
the taking of mh370.
I invested three hours in the
Netflix show.
I am not sorry I did, I learned
a lot.
But, at the end, Jeff, we still
don't know.
>> We still don't know,
Michael.
And, I think that is the point.
You know, in the months that
followed the investigators
performed this intricate
mathematical calculation that
told them where the plane lands,
and they devoted hears long
search to scanning the sea bad.
Really challenging, amazing
feat, they water there is as
deep as three miles, they
covered an area the size of
great Britain and yet the plane
was not there, so, this is
really what the documentary
series is trying to tackle.
How do we reconcile all of
those facts?
How can they have performed
this really rigorous
mathematical analysis and yet
failed to find the plane?
What could have happened?
>> I am going to play a map of
that part of the world and
asked Jeff wise, the question,
is there even consensus on what
body of water it went down in?
>> Well, I think there is kind
of the main theory and then
there is kind of everything
else, the main consensus view
is that the plane turned south,
almost certainly because the
captain had plotted out this
very elaborate murder suicide
scheme.
The plane flew south and went
to this area, and that is why
the Australian government spent
hundreds of millions dollars
search in this area, a big
commitment, but then there is
other theories, including my
theory which I attempt to piece
together and alternative
explanation that also fits what
the actual scientific evidence
in hand.
In which I sort of say that
there is this kind of
farfetched seeming series of
coincidences.
Which could result in a plane
going north to Kazakhstan.
>> People will remember, you
referenced the pilot people a
member of the revelation that
he had a flight simulator in
his home, that stuck on a
nefarious connotation.
What is the bottom line about
the pilot?
>> You know, it is one of these
things where it kind of depends
on who you ask.
A lot of people out there think,
he was going through a troubled
marriage and he had all kinds
of psychological problems.
The people who really knew him
best, the people who have had
the best most access to his
family and friends say that he
was like a very emotionally
balanced guy, very well liked,
his marriage was strong and he
was looking forward to
retirement, he put up all these
videos of him on YouTube
helping making videos showing
how to repair leaky windows and
stuff, just looking at pictures
of him he seems like a chill
guy, he was very popular, was
regarded as an excellent pilot,
I did a story the following
year about a young German pilot
who flew his plane into the
alps.
And, if you compare these two
cases the German kid was deeply
troubled, he had been pulled
from flight duty for
psychological problems, he had
searches on his computer of
searching for how to commit
suicide.
He actually had searched mh370,
almost like this incident
inspired.
Him but, you can see there is a
different kind of psychology
there, but we will never know,
the human brain is still on
fallible in some level.
>> Jeff, quick answer, is there
still an active investigation?
If not, why not?
>> It is a cold case, basically,
I mean, the file still exists,
the people who looked into and
are still around, but they have
sort of put it on the
backburner and they are waiting
to see if anything happens, I
hope this will shake the tree,
because there are so questions
that need to be asked, there is
some really hard realities that
need to be faced.
How complain was not there?
People think it is a big ocean
and they just didn't find it
because the ocean is too big
but that's not really correct.